buckle up we are only 92 days until
this election where you're the ultimate
jury and tonight the conspiracy
theorists on the left
you know the ones that sold you the
russian hoax the impeachment hoax
all of them are back in full gear hitler
comparisons
bizarre fantasies about president trump
getting forcibly removed from
office and a strange democratic a
dramatic analogy from humpty
humpty dumpty on fake news cnn just off
the rails
total psychosis but sadly predictable
now we're going to show you the worst of
the worst coming up plus we have a very
special hannity investigation
biden's 51 years of public life
many are wondering okay what
specifically has he
accomplished in over five decades in the
swamp well our special 2020
correspondent lawrence jones hit the
streets of new york to find out
if anyone could name a single
accomplishment this should be
entertaining
and later lawrence will also bring us an
exclusive investigation
into the massive crime wave in de
blasio's
new york with 1 billion in cuts for the
nypd
we're going to show you exactly what
defunding the police looks like
spoiler alert think warzone but first
tonight we start with
democratic majority whip james clyburn
he's in leadership the third highest
ranking democrat in the house
a close biden ally and this weekend well
he continued to float
yet more conspir conspiracy theories
kind of the tinfoil hat conspiracy
theories
about trump putin nazi germany
mussolini and fascism remember last week
he was comparing trump
you know using whatever he and pelosi
said gestapo tactics and other crazy
stuff
take a look do you really think donald
trump is comparable to adolf hitler
what i said started about two and a half
maybe three years ago after one of his
state of the unions
that i feel very strongly that this
man has taken on a strong arm tactics
and i feel very strongly that she
is mussolini putin is hitler
i believe very strongly this guy
never had any idea about
being one to peacefully
transfer power i believe that he
plans to install himself in some kind of
emergency way
to continue to hold on to office nazi
analogies fascist analysis
analogies what you just heard is
obviously delusional but it is the
current
favorite hoax of the radical left now
that's the same cast of democratic
extremists the same lying mob in the
media that brought you the
failed russia conspiracy theory hoax and
the failed ukraine hoax
well i now want you to believe that
donald trump
is going to refuse to leave office and
become a dictator
fake news cnn's april ryan even openly
fantasizing about the president getting
pulled out of the oval office by
armed forces take a look
so there's going to be a split screen on
january 20
2021 if joe biden is now going to be the
46th president of the united states you
will have him
being inaugurated and and watching
police and armed
forces trying to pull donald trump out
of the white house i cannot wait for
that split screen
this is deranged but sadly predictable
behavior we see it every two years and
every four years and as we now march
closer
to the election the three-month mark the
smear machine
is only going to get worse prepare
yourself for the
greatest insanity an emotional
rollercoaster well you probably have
never seen before
what do they do every two and four years
they divide this country old young rich
poor
they use racial identity politics they
have bizarre conspiracy theories
they are even getting more bizarre and
on sunday professional
fox stalker we call him affectionately
humpty dumpty
literally comparing the president to a
driver who is trying to crash his car
intentionally in humpty's well hello
dramatic scenario
the car represents our democracy we are
a democratic republic
if we can keep it as ben franklin once
warned
now democrat jamie raskin actually
accused the president of turning the gop
into a religious cult
and tonight this kind of extreme
rhetoric is not just trump derangement
syndrome
it is an intentional distraction coupled
with
derangement and real psychosis to keep
your attention away from
all things yeah the ever corrupt
confused and slow joe biden it's also
that the democrats and their state-run
socialist tv allies
they're actually scared to death that
you the american people
will re-elect donald trump as the 45th
president of the united states
and for the sake of our kids and
grandkids
and the world i pray we do they know
that joe is weak
they know he's corrupt they know his
track record is pathetic he's one of the
worst presidential candidates in history
he's hiding because of it and pelosi
schumer
bolshevik bernie aoc's policies if they
are implemented they will destroy what
is the greatest country god has given
man and put the world in great peril
without us leading
world's in deep trouble which brings us
to an important hannity history lesson
so in 51 years of public life okay
ask yourself at home what has joe biden
accomplished
i could tell you what trump has
accomplished in less than four let's
start with biden's uncanny knack for
always
making the wrong decision for example
biden opposed the
2011 navy seal raid that killed bin
laden
biden also spoke out against his sex
successful
petraeus iraq troop surge in 2007
and biden was an enthusiastic supporter
of obama's strategy to abandon the
middle east which of course left a
massive vacuum that was soon filled by
isis oh yeah and he pushed the big lie
keep your doctor plan
and save money millions lost their
doctors their plans were all paid about
200 percent more
he voted for the war in iraq now he says
a mistake
biden also on the wrong side of racial
integration
let's go to nbc news shall we he led the
charge
on an issue that kept black students
away from the classrooms of white
students
as biden once said he did not want his
children to grow up in a racial
jungle senator kamala harris now a front
runner we hear
who knows it may be a head fake for
biden's veep stakes
but just a few months ago she had this
to say about
biden's anti-integration efforts wow
take a look but i also
believe and it's personal and it was
actually very it was hurtful
to hear you talk about the reputations
of two united states senators who built
their reputations
and career on the segregation of race in
this country
and it was not only that but
you also worked with them to oppose
busing
and you know there was a little girl in
california
who was part of the second class to
integrate her public schools
and she was bussed to school every day
and that little girl was me why didn't
joe biden
at least look somebody in the eye and
listen to what they had to say
by the way kamal now wants to be biden's
running mate pretty pathetic and by the
way
biden's horrific track record doesn't
end there a few years ago during the
barack and joe days their administration
biden was the point person for ukraine
u.s relations and during that time we
already know he allowed
putin to steal crimea all while zero
experience on
well hunter got filthy rich thanks to
that sketchy deal with a
pro-russian energy company all while
leveraging
a billion dollars of your money quid pro
quo joe
zero experience hunter biden also was in
charge of the administration's china
policy and for years
joe well he did his best to cozy up to
the country's ruling communist party
all while again hunter well he struck up
yet
another lucrative deal this time with
the bank of china no spirit experience
again that anyone can find
flash forward to this year when
president trump signed off on the
life-saving travel ban
to and from china 10 days after the
first identified coronavirus case here
biden was against the ban he's the one
that called it hysterical xenophobia and
fear-mongering
how many thousands of american lives
were saved by the president's decision
ten days after that first case in the
u.s
and by the way to do that while he was
also being impeached
joe wrong as usual so with such a
horrific track record well we sent our
own
lawrence jones our 2020 correspondent he
went out to the streets of new york to
see if anyone could just name a single
positive achievement from biden's five
decades of public life
i haven't seen this yet this is going to
be interesting
what would you say is joe biden's
signature accomplishment
president obama's right-hand man that's
enough for you
that's plenty what is one accomplishment
for joe biden he's been in politics for
47 years
yeah i i don't know what i don't know
he's a nice man he smiles a lot
and i don't see any kind of strength
any kind of inner strength in him to
lead a nation that's an
absolute mess right now you're a i'm a
democrat
biden is your person he's been in office
for like 47 years
what would you say is his number one
accomplishment uh
that again do people come together he
brings people together yeah
better than of course than donald trump
biden is
the guy it's unfortunate that that's all
they have now
they can't answer he smiles he's nice he
was selected vp
what did he do for we the people